just to linger on liberal arts in 2014
and probably still today you wrote that
Liberals are killing the liberal arts
yes so can you explain
yes the problem with I'm a political
liberal
the problem with the the political left
is that it has divided
between what's called progressives
and liberals
liberals or people of the left who
believe in the First Amendment an
absolute First Amendment and in due
process of law
and um
the the problem with with progressives
now
in the pursuit of
equality what they view as equality
they're willing to bend those rules and
this movement actually started in
Brandeis
um the um the critical it's the critical
race Theory
it started Herbert Marcus it was a
professor of Brandeis and he came up
with this Theory the theory was this
this is right out of War will
in order to create true equality in a
society where you have some downtrodden
and some who are The Uber mentioned
in order to create real
um equality you have to reduce the
rights of the upper classes and
artificially increase the rights of the
lower classes
and um
that will produce
unequal treatment
true equality will be will be attained
this is nonsense
the idea of discrimination
producing true equality is nonsense
my view is as I've said earlier in our
discussion that the way to
increase the opportunities
for the lower classes is to give them
real educations
and until we do that it's not going to
happen and in order to do that we have
to overcome
the problem of the teachers unions at
the elementary and secondary school
levels until we're willing to do that
honestly
and then improve those schools we're
going to have a problem of a large
number of uneducated people
who need a boost because we haven't
given them proper educations
what do you think about some of the more
controversial faculty in the world so an
example somebody I've spoken with many
times on Mike and offline is Jordan
Peterson I'm not sure if you're familiar
with his work yes but he's an outspoken
critic of uh or proponent of free speech
on campus and he's been attacked quite a
bit
he's a controversial figure
which threw all of the university to
protect the Jordan Petersons of the
world I think the university has an
absolute absolute not relative not water
that absolute role obligation to protect
the academic freedom of even the most
controversial
faculty members
and you can imagine at a University
campus you have more people who are
outliers than you do in the general
population
um and um that's the hope at least
hopefully yeah
and and um and those outliers have to be
protected
they can't be pressure they can't be
fired they can't be disabled from
spewing their their views whether
they're considered racist whether
they're considered to be you know a
promote an idea of human society that's
considered obnoxious
um it doesn't matter if you can't if if
you can't have freedom of thought on the
college campuses where can you you know
then we're lost as a society we're lost
and as an educational institution
um educational institutions no longer
will educate they will indoctrinate
that we have to avoid at all costs and
we should also remember that the outlier
might also be the only bearer of Truth
so in Nazi Germany speaking against the
fascism fascist regime and uh communist
Soviet Union speaking against communism
they might hold the key to the solving
the ailments of that Society absolutely
and some of the most important
discoveries in science for example
were were mocked at the beginning I mean
think of poor Charlie Darwin Charlie I
see he is on nickname uh levels with you
uh well because we're talking about
these big topics of sexism and racism
and hate they should not forget about
the smaller topics which might even have
the much bigger impact which is what
you're speaking to which is uh outlier
uh ideas and science so basically
welcome welcoming controversial ideas in
science and by controversial I mean just
stuff that that uh most the community
doesn't agree on it doesn't actually
harm anyone at all but even then there's
always pressure one of the things I'm
really concerned about is how little
power young faculty have
that there's a kind of hierarchy
seniority that's uh that universities
have empowered by the administration
where young faculty that come in they're
kind of uh
pre-tenured yeah there's a there's a
process in chasing tenure where you're
kind of supposed to behave
and there's an uh incentive to kind of
fit in and to not be an outcast and that
that's a really huge problem because
oftentimes the youth
is when the craziest the biggest ideas
the revolution ideas come and if you're
forced to behave and fit in and not
speak out then even in the realm of
science the The Innovation is stifled
well now you now you trigger my uh yeah
I'll tell you this story that you're
triggered this is good
in the mid-1980s I decided to take a
four month sabbatical from my law
practice yes
Professor James vorenberg who is at the
time dean of the Harvard Law School
heard about it heard about it from his
wife Elizabeth Betty vorenberg
whom I was very friendly with because we
were both on the acou the ACLU of
Massachusetts board at the time
and um so Betty told Jim
that Harvey was taking a sabbatical
Jim called Harvey and asked Harvey if he
would like to teach a course at the
Harvard Law School because there was
nobody who had
teaching criminal law from the
perspective of somebody who actually was
in court litigated
it was all theoretical
I said sure I'll do it
so I taught a semester at Harvard Law
School
the student evaluations were fabulous
why because it was really interesting
they were hearing a lawyer who's talking
about real cases I actually brought in a
few of my clients some of the classes
and um so Jim called me and said hurry
the students loved this course I'd like
to offer you a tenure track position
at the law school you'd have to give up
your law practice I turned him down
he said
did you just say no I said yes I said no
he said how come he says nobody ever has
ever in my Administration
has ever turned down a tenure track
offer at Harvard Law School
I said because I could see that I'm not
a good fit
that the administrators are overrun the
place
that faculty members especially
untenured who are afraid to say things
that might not get help them in the
tenure Quest
um it's um it's not a good fit for me
you saw this in the mid 1980s already
yes 1985.
and um I went back to my law practice I
I did not want to get into this me
crying that that I saw after all I had I
started to see it before the turn of the
century because I co-authored the shadow
University in 98.
and then co-founded fire in 99 I was
early student of this phenomenon
what are some other aspects of this uh
the book The Shadow University that we
may have not covered well let me let me
tell you a story I believe I tell it the
shadow University because it was part of
I'm loving these stories Harvey the
stories are fabulous let me tell you a
story of um
um I I I I did a tour of the country go
visiting campuses
I visited a college called Hamline
University I believe it was in Indiana
or Illinois somewhere in the Midwest
and I I attended a freshman orientation
now listen to this
this was a freshman orientation
the administrators
the Deans and the dnets and the deputy
assistant Deans and Dean hats and that
that third Deputy assistant Deans and
dinas lined the students up according to
their skin hues
oh boy the the blonde blue-eyed white
folks were at one end
the darkest
um you know
African-Americans who had whose
Bloodlines had not yet mixed with any of
the whites
on the other room and the exercise was
you had to tell how you erase affected
your success in life up until that point
I thought it was the most demeaning
thing that I could imagine
demeaning I thought to myself they could
do the same about sexual orientation
they could do the same about religion
they could just have a national origin
it would be demeaning no matter what
yeah and and the students actually
verbalized how their race had either
Been A Plus or a minus they did they did
and I thought it was so demeaning it
just confirmed all of my distaste for
this kind of uh
this kind of approach